[Music]
the big reveal
coming in the last several chapters of
philip jose farmer's
novella the lovers is that one of the
lovers
jeanette rasignac is indeed not
half human but entirely
unhuman and she has been mating
and falling in love with hal yarrow a
human
from earth and there's a
long discussion in chapter 19
about this creature called the la litha
and this comes in the form of a lot of
exposition
on the part of one of the woggle bugs
hal's friend
fobo it's also
within a you could call it legalistic
framework where
hal is getting in trouble with his own
people
and one of the things that fobo says
is particularly interesting the lalitha
was nature's most amazing experiment
in parasitism and parallel
evolution what we found is that at least
in this narrative universe
on osagan and on earth there have been
parallel
evolutions taking place and there are
parasitical
creatures not necessarily parasitical in
the sense
of like living off the flesh of others
but using them in certain ways and the
lalitha
is something like this so
this is a very important
turning point that we'll talk about for
a few minutes there are
some foreshadowings of it early on
that unless you've read through you're
not necessarily going to
pick up on one of these is where
they're having a discussion hal says all
god's creatures have their
proper place in the universe actually
backing up a little bit
um she's talking about
uh the you know the worries that the
waggle bugs had about
her race they thought there might be
some males of my race left in the jungle
i might give them children they're
terribly frightened of my race becoming
numerous and strong again
and making war on them hal says they are
strange beings but we cannot unders we
cannot expect to understand
those who do not know the reality of the
forerunner he's saying listen unless
they know
you know our philosophy our metaphysics
coming from this great revealer
they're not really completely human
they're closer to the insect than man
and jeanette says being a man does not
necessarily mean being better she says
this with a tinge of a sparity like a
little bit of
edge to it and so then hal says all
god's creatures have their proper place
in the universe
but man's place is everywhere and every
when he can occupy any position in space
and can travel any in any direction in
time
and if he must dispossess a creature to
gain that place or time
he's doing only what is right she says
quoting the forerunner of course
and then she says perhaps he's right
perhaps but
what is man this is really a key
issue is it is it to be you know human
being with human dna or is it to have
the rational capacities of a human being
or is it to have the capacities for
emotion and relationships and morality
right so she says man is a sentient
being a wag is a sentient being
therefore the [ __ ] is a man
nespah and uh you know he says
[ __ ] or seb let's not argue why don't we
eat
she says i wasn't arguing and so that's
that's a very important
prefiguration right because she is not
man she is something different
a little bit later he says you have
amazing
imitative powers i've watched you
copying
my movements heard you mimic my speech
do you know that you pronounce american
as well as
i do and she says show or tell me
something once and you seldom have to do
it again
i'm not claiming a superior intelligence
however
as you said i have an instinct for
imitation
not that i'm not capable of an original
thought
now and then so that's you know
that's her nature right so that's a very
important foreshadowing
as well a little bit later on there's
uh more discussions um
where you know they're talking about uh
sexuality and love and then finally
here's another one they're talking about
her background her
her back story my father's people found
a planet like earth
settled it was a beautiful planet that's
why they called it wubba fee the
beautiful land
so and then they came to oz again
crashed
he says is the wreck still around fee
meaning c
right we close to where my sisters and
aunts and cousins live your mother is
dead
she hesitated than nodded yes she died
giving birth to me
and my sisters my father died later or
rather
we think he did so this is quite
interesting as well isn't it my
mother died giving birth to me and my
sisters
so is is she a member of triplets
what's going on there well as we're
going to find out
this is the way that birth and
reproduction works for the lalitha
there's a big reveal as we talked about
and it turns out that
everybody or not exactly everybody but
at least everybody who matters in the
scene
already knew that hal was having
sex and falling in love with and
essentially being married to
a completely non-human species
which had however evolved
in in relation to humans in
the humans on the planet to be connected
with them everybody knew including the
the woggle bugs
everybody knew including of course
jeanette herself
and the
you could call them security forces and
managerial functions of the
hijack confederacy people now
fobo engages in some lengthy exposition
not all of which we're going to discuss
here we're just going to hit on some of
the key points but there's there's a
long
passage particularly in chapter 19 where
he's telling us about this
species of pseudo-arthropoda
and how things actually work with them
so what do we have going on
here we have a species that has adapted
itself like he says the lalitha are the
highest example of memetic
parasitism known they're unique among
sentient beings unique in that
all are female and he says i gave you
this book
and you didn't read it this is another
bit of the foreshadowing i should have
mentioned
the book that he's referencing is one
where jeannette starts reading a bit of
it
and then says oh this is boring let's
let's move on to something else instead
so he says fossil evidence shows that
about the time that
azeogenia and man was still an
insectivorous marmoset-like creature
he had in his family group not only his
own females but the females of another
phylum these animals looked and probably
stank enough like the females of
pre-homo marmoset
to be able to live and mate with him
they seem a million
but dissection would have indicated
their pseudo-arthropodal
ancestry so they're not bugs they're not
insects
they're not mammals either there's
something else that's
kind of closer to the waggle bug and
other things
so he says as man metamorph
metamorphosed into higher forms so the
lalitha kept
pace with him all female depending on
the male of another phylum for the
continuance of their
species and it goes on there's a whole
bunch of things about tribal lore
um uh you know how they they gained
mastery over their lovers belonging to a
secret society
i'm we're interested more here in how
things actually work
so he says you won't understand what has
happened how unless you comprehend the
lalitha's
unique method of reproduction three
things the lalitha needs to reproduce
one thing must precede the other two the
primary event is to be infected at the
age of puberty by another adult lalitha
this is needed to transmit genes so the
lalitha circulate their genes
among themselves they don't receive any
genes from the human
male but they use the human male as a
means and he says
an adult lalitha is three so-called
banks of genes
two are duplicates of each other's
chromosomal stuff the third i will
explain in a moment a lolita's uterus
contains ova the genes of which are
duplicated
in the bodies of microscopic wrigglers
formed in the giant salivary glands in a
lalitha's
mouth they pass these genes
and then after that they build up
antibodies against reception of these
from the second lalitha
meanwhile the first wrigler she's
exposed to have made their way through
the bloodstream
until they arrive at the uterus of the
host there the salivary ovum unites with
the uterine home so
it's sort of like a sperm and egg in
that case right and so these are how the
chromosomes are being passed on
but he says all except for
the fertilization is suspended all
genetic data needed to produce a new
lalitha is provided all except for the
genes for the specific features
of the face of the baby this data will
be given by the male
human lover of the lolitha not however
until the conjunction of two more events
the two must occur simultaneously one is
excitation by orgasm
the other is stimulation of the
photokinetic nerves so what happens
it goes on to explain listen only the
lollipop have these photokinetic nerves
that go all the way from the the brain
and the eyes down
to the the uterus when the lalitha
is having sex with the male lover
she in effect takes a picture of him her
pupils go to pinpoints his face
occupies the entire her visual scene
there must be light
and the resulting child is going to look
well children a brood is going to
look like him and
he goes on and says the la litho no
matter how
human she looks cannot escape her
arthropod heritage
the nymphs that develop from the larvae
can easily pass for babies but it would
pain you to see the larvae
themselves it is a sad thing that the
lalitha mother must die
hundreds of millions of years ago when a
primitive pseudo-arthropod was ready to
hatch the eggs in her womb
a hormone was released in her body it
calcified the skin
and turns her into a womb tomb she
becomes a shell
the larvae eats her bones and organs the
bones have been decalcified
and then they they rest and they come
out uh
and and break out through the navel
which does not calcify
um so she says the navel is both
functional and
mimetic since the larvae are not
connected to the mother by an umbilical
cord
they would have no navel but they grow a
crescents that resembles one they also
have breasts
which have two functions they're sexual
and reproductive they never produce milk
but they are
glands and they act as powerful pumps of
the hormone which carries out the
hardening
of the skin and so
hal is actually curious and he says well
why do they need to reproduce the
characteristics of the father's face
and fobo says i don't know perhaps the
pre-human lalitha did not utilize these
nerves maybe those are
an evolutionary adaptation of an
existing structure
that had a different function or a
vestigial function
but this does seem to be you know what
the the case
is and so he's explaining how this takes
place
alcohol by the way turns out to have
been
the thing that suppresses reproduction
and how by trying to nurse
his seemingly alcoholic wife
and lover jeannette by using a
substitute
inadvertently brought about the
conditions for her to
become not pregnant as such but rather
to reach that point in the reproductive
cycle where the already fertilized
ovum could be imprinted with his face
and become babies and then she becomes
sick essentially calcifying
and that is the end of it now there are
different reactions to what is going on
we see that the other hijack people
particularly mcneff
and the other hijacks find this
disgusting
they are in horror and rage that
um according to them hal would defile
his humanity by as he's going to say
lying with an insect right
um so that that is is uh you know
something that is completely forbidden
um
you know now of course it's a it's a
pretty repressive
society here he goes you who have passed
the aloha meter and supposed to be so
pure you're lusted
after and laying with an insect a thing
that is
even lower than a beast of the field
right so this is a
particularly gross kind of bestiality
it's not even like bestiality like
having sex with sheep it's having sex
with a fly
or a crustacean or something like that
he says
moses did not even think of that when he
forbade union between man and beast
what even the forerunner could not have
guessed when he reaffirmed the law
and set the utmost penalty for it you
have done
hugh hal gyero and
that's that's pretty much the consistent
thing he's going to be taken back to
earth
and punished fobo and the woggle bugs
have a very different attitude towards
things they call themselves the most
realist of the realists right and they
express
you know good will and helpfulness they
they understand what jeanette is going
through
they they take the uh you know boom tomb
of jeanette and the baby's off and um
fobo was even going to do something
beyond just explaining things he's going
to
speak for jeanette at the end what is
hal's attitude this is very interesting
he is a lover he feels grief
for the loss of jeanette for her death
he also you know expresses you know fobo
is going to console him and say listen
you know you got you got babies to raise
um you know you'll find other women like
this because jeanette had a bunch of
sisters and aunts so you know you can
copulate with them and they'll they'll
console you that'll be nice for you and
he's saying
maybe someday but right now i'm going to
grieve he
also expresses love and this is
where we get to one of the really
interesting
aspects so fobo tells him
i'm sorry i'm just trying to make you
see why jeanette
felt she couldn't tell you what she
truly was
she must have loved you hal she
possessed the three factors
that make love a genuine passion
a deep affection and the feeling of
being
one flesh with you male and female so
inseparable it would be hard to tell
where one began
and the other ended i know that she did
believe me
for we empathists can put ourselves into
somebody else's nervous system
and think and feel as they do
before we go on i want to hit back on
those three features right
genuine passion deep affection
and a feeling of being one flesh with
the other
this is possible in this story
not just between human beings or beings
of other species like wobble bugs
but across species jeanette so loves
hell
that she exhibits these things towards
them and that is why she doesn't reveal
what she is he goes on and says jeanette
must have had a bitter leaven in her
love
the belief that if you knew she was of
an utterly alien branch of the animal
kingdom
separated by millions of years of
evolution barred by her ancestry and
anatomy of the true completion of
marriage children
you would turn from her with horror the
belief must have shot with darkness even
her brighter moments and then hal
says no i would have loved her anyway it
might have been a shock but i'd have
gotten over it
why she was human she was more human
than any woman that i've known which
goes back to the prefiguring where
jeanette
and hal are having this discussion well
who is indeed human and this is one of
the
key themes so we come back sort of full
circle talking about this other species
that is developed
in terms of parasitism parallel
evolution
mimesis is it human or not and
can it love and can there be love
between it
and the humans that
are involved with it and farmers answer
in fobo and hal's words and jeannette as
well
is yes
you